Kim's first public sighting in three
days comes at the same time as this new
headline claiming Kim security team is
searching for a body double Kim has come
face to face with a look like on her
show well there's Kim nice to meet two
finally today I'm told that Kim of
course is still pretty emotional she's
having flashbacks to when she was bound
and gagged and held at gunpoint by those
robbers a hearing that she tries not to
cry in front of North but it's been
tough and that of course leads to Kim's
fears for her children even the
possibility of them being kidnapped I
want you to stay little forever Kim has
never been shy plastering north and st.
all over social media the one thing that
will be changing though is Kim and her
use of social media my source is telling
me today that she's taking a break from
everything including work and posting
her life Kim realizes that the way she
showed off all her diamonds and her
wealth on snapchat and Instagram could
have been a factor in all this and maybe
she shouldn't have flaunted it so much
you can definitely be sure that we'll be
seeing a lot less of that in the future
but come on we all know posting every
single detail of her life as part of
Kim's DNA how will cutting back on
social media change her reported 150
million dollar brand in some ways it can
actually elevate her brand because look
she's been under attack there are many
people that are saying this was a hoax
tone it down Kim keep it real you are
hunted and the scent is social media